when did LeBron become the Beast that he
is LeBron went to the Olympics and they
recruited Kobe to go to the Olympics go
study Lebron after he went to the
Olympics with Kobe because he noticed
Kobe was maniacal about his training
nobody ever had the standers of Kobe
including Michael Michael had better
god-given ability but Michael wanted to
party and do all the other stuff
everybody who ever played with Kobe
realized this guy's a monster Alan
Iverson one of my favorite players to
watch he tells a story one time he says
hey one time I'm playing against the
Lakers I said hey Co what are you doing
L let's go to dinner we go to dinner and
then CO's like what are you doing now
I'm going to go to the club you want a
roll says no I'll take you he goes drops
him off at the club Kobe does he says
where you going he say I got to go back
to the gym to practice we talking about
practice Kobe's got five championships
ai's got zero